now that we've had our hands on apple's
m1 macbook air and macbook pro for over
two months
i figured i'd revisit the topic of which
one of these m1 max you should buy
except this time there's a twist
what if you should actually hold off and
wait for the future
redesigned apple silicon macbooks
instead because yes
we are expecting some new fully
redesigned models in the near future
and i'm going to be talking about all of
those leaks and rumors
and what to expect from them and believe
it or not some people will
actually be much better off buying an m1
mac
right now instead of waiting but before
i get into
all of that i want to talk about the
differences between the
air and the pro after two full months
first
let me quickly cover the main hardware
differences that
actually matter the macbook air is
completely fanless
while the pro does have one fan the pro
comes with an 8 core gpu at the base
price instead of 7 with the air the pro
also gets a larger 58.2 watt hour
battery
compared to 49.9 on the air and
finally the macbook air starts at 999
compared to 12.99 for the pro those are
the major hardware differences between
the two
so at first glance it seems like the air
is a much
better value and after two months i've
gotta admit that it definitely
is but there are some reasons that
people should be buying the macbook pro
instead and i'll explain in just a
second on the exterior the main
difference is the shape
with the air being more of a wedge shape
instead of a flat slate
shape on the pro because of that
difference the air is a bit more
comfortable for typing
since your palm doesn't dig into the
edge of the macbook
like on the pro by far the biggest
difference is the fact that the air gets
the traditional
function keys while the pro gets the
touch bar
that many people don't like now i
personally prefer
the function keys because i never really
got much use out of the touch bar
in most apps it's easier and faster to
just
use keyboard shortcuts and for adjusting
brightness and audio settings
the function keys are hands down the
better option
what makes this even more interesting
are some very recent leaks and rumors
that point to apple finally ditching the
touch bar
and going back to function keys on the
future macbook pros
and i'm gonna get into the rest of those
interesting leaks in just a minute now
getting back to the air versus pro
the other major difference is the
battery life even though the physical
battery itself
is only around 16 larger on the macbook
pro
somehow the battery life is much much
better
linus tech tips tested the video
playback and they found that the pro's
battery lasted
over 20 hours which is incredible
and it lasted about 7 hours longer than
the macbook air
that's over 50 percent better battery
life with a battery that's only
16 larger and i'd say that this
is by far the biggest factor when you're
trying to decide between these two
now i'm not trying to say that the
battery life on the macbook air is bad
it's better than basically every windows
laptop ever
but the pro is just on a whole nother
level so if battery life is
incredibly important to you then paying
an extra three hundred dollars
is definitely worth it but if you don't
really go out much
and you don't mind plugging it in a
little bit more often
then the air is definitely fine now in
terms of performance
the air is more than enough for most
people even those who need it for
productivity work
like general photo and video editing in
our testing the air held up
extremely well in terms of everything
from logic pro
music production xcode programming
final cut video editing and lightroom
classic
photo editing and those are all tasks
that the intel macbook airs
have never been good at now because of
the m1 chip
you can finally do those tasks with
excellent performance
but the main advantage is that it's
completely
fanless so you never have to worry about
the fan kicking on
ever again with the previous macbook air
the fan would turn on
at the weirdest times like when simply
browsing the web
or even worse while on a zoom call or
watching a movie
which can get extremely annoying since
you can't hear it that well
with the m1 no fan means absolutely
zero noise and even while doing high
performance work
it doesn't get nearly as hot as the
previous intel macbooks would get
no fans also means no dust clogging the
internals of your macbook
which leads to blocked airflow and
overheating
after just a couple of years of use now
because of all of that
it might seem like the added fan on the
pro model
isn't so great after all but after two
months of use
we've noticed that we barely even hear
the fan on the pro
at all we use the fan and temp tracking
app
named tg pro and while doing basic tasks
like web browsing
watching videos or other things like
that the fan on the pro
is almost always completely turned off
not running at all and when doing light
productivity work
the fan turns on but it stays at around
idle speed
and at those speeds you can't hear it
unless you literally put your ear to the
back of the macbook pro
and that's just incredible so because of
that we decided to run
the most intensive heavy workloads on
both of these macbooks
to see if the fan actually made a real
world difference
we exported 500 raw 42 megapixel photos
in lightroom classic
which is just about the heaviest
workload you can put on the cpu and the
ram
and we were honestly expecting a much
bigger difference
the pro was only three and a half
minutes faster
than the fanless air we then switched
over to the graphics side and exported
an 8k
red rock clip in final cut pro which
basically maxes out the graphics
and uses a ton of cpu power and the pro
was only two and a half minutes faster
so to be completely honest
that big of a difference is not worth
the extra 300
for the pro especially since the air
doesn't even have a fan
we then tested out gaming and here there
was actually a difference
with the pro getting around 11 higher
frames per second
but that's only because the pro comes
with an 8 core gpu
compared to 7 on the air we later tested
the top 10 most popular games on twitch
with the m1 macbook pro and we noticed
that after most of the games
the fan speed was barely above idle
which was really impressive considering
that most other laptops
get very loud while gaming but i've
gotta say that if you're crazy about
gaming the future m1x macbooks
are going to be much better as we're
expecting a 16 core gpu
which is going to handle many games
extremely well so if you're all about
gaming
you might want to wait and hold off for
just a little bit longer but getting
back to the air versus pro
i've got to say that if you're trying to
get the best performance
for the buck you should probably just
get the air
and save that 300 and if you really want
to upgrade something
i'd either upgrade the storage or go for
16 gigs of ram
which can help for photo editing and
heavy multitasking
so if i had to close the m1 macbook air
versus pro topic i'd honestly have to
say that
almost everybody should just buy the air
for the better value and this finally
brings us to some more leaks
to solidify our conclusion on not going
for the m1 macbook pro just a few days
ago
both mingxiko and mark german released
reports claiming that
two redesigned macbook pro models are
coming later this year
with quo pointing to a summer release
date now i personally think it makes
sense for apple to announce these
at this year's wwdc conference since
that's when they initially announced
the apple silicon transition last year
but i guess we're just gonna have to
wait and see
in terms of the redesign changes quo is
expecting both 14
and 16-inch macbook pro models with mini
led displays
a new flat edge design like we currently
have on the iphone 12 and the ipad pro
the return of the magsafe charging
connector
more types of ports and of course the
removal of
the touch bar so if you're looking at
the current 13-inch macbook pro
you should definitely consider waiting
just a few more months for these new
models
because apple is likely going to stick
with this new redesign
for many years and these new pros
will also come with a more powerful m1x
chip however i'm almost 100 sure
that the 14 inch macbook pro is gonna
start at either eighteen hundred
or two thousand dollars so if there's no
way you're willing to pay
that much for a laptop then you should
not
wait for them and you might as well just
get an m1 model right now
now on top of those leaks for the pro
models we also have multiple sources
confirming that the next macbook air is
only going to come out in 2022
and if apple releases it in the fall
like they did with the m1 model
that basically means that there won't be
an updated macbook air
for almost two more years and it's
rumored to get the new mini led display
the full redesign and it's likely to
come with a new three nanometer chip
but to be honest it doesn't make sense
to wait that long
before buying a new macbook especially
if you're interested right now
so here's the final rundown if the m1
max
perform well enough for your needs and
you don't want to wait a few months
to spend at least eighteen hundred
dollars on
a new 14-inch macbook pro then we think
that based on all of our testing
most people should probably just buy the
m1
macbook air for 999 dollars
right now especially since the
redesigned model
is not coming until 2022. so hopefully
this video helped you make a decision
and if it did you can find the best
deals on these macbooks down in the
description below
and if you enjoyed this video go ahead
and click the circle above to subscribe
and definitely check out one of those
two videos right over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]